obviously the film does a wonderful job
of telling us a little bit about the
history of HIV and AIDS
but what was it what was it like to make
a film in that climate what was the
setting of the time the landscape that
you were making this important film well
we were all living it for sure I mean
this was our experience that we were
living with we had no I we had no
perspective at that point really we just
didn't know where we were in the course
of the epidemic except to know that it
was only gonna get worse but we had no
sense of when it might get better I felt
that we were blessed in a way that we
this combination here had the
connections and these whatever we had
what it took to get this paid for at a
time when people didn't do stuff on AIDS
until they did news stories but I mean
for me it was why I got into the film
business was to be able to do things
that actually could matter and I think
that's true for all of us here so I mean
it was depressing of course but it just
I felt like okay we can do something
because you felt powerless it was the
scariest time because every one of my
single friends were dying or sick and I
even thought I was sick for a minute I'm
not thank God but it was such a scary
time and we were motivated by anger and
injustice and you know Reagan not
mentioning the word AIDS it was just a
terrible terrible time and these guys
were very heroic and certainly
we also I've been doing a film like this
is in some ways it's a it's a form of
emotional protection because you feel
like you're doing something so it's a
way to focus your you know all those
feelings and emotions that you know
you're experiencing but we also knew it
was an opportunity I mean once HBO came
on board we knew we were making a film
for a mainstream audience and that
hadn't been done yet so there was a
certain responsibility that went along
with that but also a great opportunity
how long has it been since you've seen
the panels that are featured in the film
and yeah what's it like to see it today
well for me I I I just think my friends
my friends who should be here and that
makes me very sad and it also makes me
very grateful and it makes me very
grateful that I've had so much more
opportunity than they got to have in
their lifetimes and they're with us
always it made me think of of how a
community can come together and fight
back in the face of really daunting odds
and it made me just wish that people
were inspired to rise up and figure out
ways of fighting the the forces that we
need to be fighting right now
i-i've had I can't believe that I'm
saying this but I've had 2700 friends
that died of AIDS and I have a list and
if I didn't keep that list that would
remember them and my whole life since 81
has been all about grief and loss and
when I heard about this thing the 30
year anniversary and the doubt fest and
that the Academy and you know these
three gentlemen we're gonna put this on
again I said to myself this will give a
chance for young people to actually see
what we went through and it's really
powerful
[Applause]